hi everybody i hope you're enjoying
cloud next so far
in this session we're going to talk to
you about the value of getting a google
cloud certification
to help you in your career and to help
advance the projects that you're
involved in in the world of cloud
computing my name is brian rice and i
work on google cloud's learning
portfolio
and i'm joined today by my colleague
osaze
hello everyone my name is
and i'm a technical program manager in
google global networking really excited
to be here and looking forward to this
talk
thank you so much um here's the way
we're going to structure our recession
i'm going to kick it off by talking
about the roles that are out there in
the world of cloud computing and their
demand and how that's shaping and
changing
as we move further and further into the
cloud era
i'm going to talk about the learning
resources that google cloud makes
available to help people achieve
a wide range of google cloud
certifications
then i'm going to bring on osase and
he's going to tell us about how
certifications helped him propel his
career path
finally we'll wrap it up by talking
about the benefits of google cloud
certifications both to the people who
achieve them and to the teams that
they're a part of
let's start off by talking about the
demand for cloud computing roles
we recently did a survey where leaders
were asked about the barriers that they
had to cloud success and over 80 percent
of them identified a skills gap on their
team as a top barrier
and this is a really significant problem
if you think about the fact that more
than 90 of those leaders expect to have
increased use of cloud over the next
three years
this tells us that skills are a critical
factor in companies move to the cloud
and we know it's a it's a growing
importance to the cloud community
because job postings that were
specifically calling for cloud skills
grew by more than 40 percent
over the two years that ended in the
first quarter of 2021
and of course there was a lot of change
and a lot of upheaval over that period
this significant growth tells us about
the fact that
skills are fuel for companies moving
into the cloud and revolutionizing the
way they work
we at google cloud are especially proud
of the fact that in a survey conducted
by global knowledge
the top two paying i.t certifications in
the year 2021 in the u.s were both
google cloud certifications
we take this both as testimonial to the
value of google cloud itself and also to
the programs that we offer
for recognizing people skills and
helping people train themselves up so
that they can achieve those credentials
now
cloud computing
always requires an approach to
learning and credentialing that is
focused on job roles
after all uh the roles that people play
is how people get value out of cloud
computing google cloud technology
training
is aimed at cloud solutions rather than
following particular products boundaries
and it's keyed to the solutions that
customers tried to pursue which was
their reason for getting into the cloud
in the first place
now i'd like to talk with you about the
resources that we make available to help
people skill up
and the certifications that we make
available to recognize people's skill
levels
now when you're leading a team of
professionals
um you have to keep in mind that people
are all starting at different places
everybody in the team starts with a wide
variety of existing skill levels
also people have different preferred
learning styles the same kind of
learning experience doesn't work for
everybody
so that's why we offer a wide variety of
choices for people consuming our
offerings
some people prefer to consume training
in a traditional classroom style format
either with a live instructor or with
virtual instructor-led training we have
a worldwide network of authorized
training partners that does just that
other learners want the increased
convenience and flexibility of consuming
online training with virtual lectures an
online assessments
in order to help these people we make
our training available in online
channels as well for online partners
both of those two modes contain the same
hands-on labs in which people can gain
real-world skills using
real google cloud not a simulation that
gives them the confidence to do new
things on the job
finally some learners want a maximum
amount of flexibility they want all our
cart learning snackable learning that's
why we also make available a wide
portfolio of hands-on lab exercises that
can be consumed individually
in a safe sandbox environment
now
all of these lead up to achieving
professional and associate level
certifications these are benchmarks that
a team can adopt to bring everybody up
to a baseline of skill that's how they
know they have the right foundation for
innovating and for scaling up
now the benchmark concept is very very
important in the way we build our
certifications
their content is defined by subject
matter experts and they're keyed to real
world job roles and the
the uses to which people put google
cloud technology that's why google cloud
certifications have significant benefit
not just to individuals but to companies
as well
they're a well-defined set of skills
that fuels growth
there's a wide variety of certifications
because we know that people start at
different points and because we know
that people have a wide variety of
interests
the certifications range from being
targeted at people with no prior cloud
skills or experience
all the way up to people who have three
years or more of industry experience and
in a wide variety of subject matter
our certifications are organized into
three main categories
two of these categories contain
certifications that are aimed at
hands-on technical professionals the
associate level and the professional
level certifications here's the
difference
associate level certifications such as
associate cloud engineer
challenge the candidate for the search
to map from technical requirements to
the way a customer would implement a
solution
the professional level of certifications
introduces one more layer
challenging the candidate to map from
business requirements through technical
requirements to the details of the way
the customer implementation would work
finally our credential that is aimed at
anyone involved in or impacted by the
move to the cloud cloud digital leader
contains three main bodies of knowledge
that it covers
general cloud knowledge knowledge of
google cloud in particular and awareness
of the business value and role of a
variety of important google cloud
services
let me give you more information about
the exams we make available
they're a two-hour experience and
they're offered in a multiple choice and
multiple select format
the exams don't have prerequisites in
that you are not required to complete
any specific training or any specific
prior certifications in order to attempt
them
we do recommend that people have
hands-on experience for our
certifications that call for that in
their descriptions and we also encourage
people to structure their preparation
and make sure they come in with the
knowledge that each credential calls for
but no prerequisites in the realm of
training or other certifications are
enforced
the exams are delivered at your choice
of either a remote location in which
case the proctoring for the exams is
done online or you can go to a physical
testing center and take an exam in an
on-site proctored system
finally we make available
official study guides uh in addition to
all of the other resources that we make
available these books are available from
major resellers of books
at this point i'd like to bring osazzi
on uh asazi uh we wanted to ask you to
join us today to tell us about your um
your career journey through the lens of
certification can i ask you to start off
by telling us about
your career path before the cloud
sure brian so my career has spanned
approximately two decades
and i've had a variety of roles from
hands-on um to technical leadership to
just pure leadership
roles and
i would say that certifications and
learning and relearning has been a key
component and enable me progress through
from
being an engineer up into leadership
positions
why do i say this
um early on in my career i started out
you know trying to build infrastructures
for
companies and deliver their i.t
solutions internally but i found that
the moment i added certifications and
that learning experience to my journey
it accelerated
one my knowledge my learning and then
also my scope of responsibility so it's
something that has worked very well for
me in my career and it's something that
i continue to
uh produce and reuse over and over
super
and tell us more about what happened
when you started moving into the cloud
sure so before
the journey to the cloud um
my organization would uh
procure
build and operate our own internal
resources so think of private cloud
and at some point
we realized that the cost and also the
time to delivery
made us not meet certain business
requirements and we had to start looking
at the option of moving some of those
workloads to the cloud now we didn't
migrate everything over all in one day
we started out in a step-by-step process
by
doing the trial for certain non-critical
workloads first to get a feel for
how things will operate in the cloud and
also um what the security framework
would be because that is a huge
consideration for anyone trying to make
that journey into the cloud
over time as the team got more confident
in using resources and understanding the
products in the cloud we're able to move
even
critical workloads into the cloud and
one of the benefits which i think is
perhaps well known in the industry is um
you when you run your own resources
internally you most often plan for peak
demand and that means that a lot of
times you have resources idling not
being used whereas in the cloud in a
more paper used model you're able to
more effectively
use resources and also
spend reduce your spend if you plan your
resources properly
indeed well to sum up can you tell us
now about how how certifications played
a role in your own
transition to the cloud
sure so
i've always enjoyed
learning and re relearning so for me
certifications helped me focus my
attention over a period of time
to to
learn that new technology or learn that
whatever is new in that space so an
example with google cloud is
over a couple of years i was aware of
you know using google cloud platform and
also some other
providers but when i made that conscious
effort to say i'm going to get certified
it helped focus and narrow
my learning to make sure that i mastered
the content and understood the products
and offerings and how they related to my
business the end result is i've been
able to achieve certifications in some
of the professional level
engineer programs like the professional
cloud architect
data professional and some of the other
professional level certificate
certifications
why i find these helpful is
it helps it helps cover a range of
topics that are relevant to the business
of
i.t and computing today and the
certification itself provides you know
knowledge that is for sure it gives you
the confidence to be able to interact
with either external or internal
peers or customers
it also gives you that um
uh
confidence
uh and as well there's also the google
swag in terms of the goodies the bags
and all the other nice things that
google gives you when you're certified
that's so true
thank you so much osazu for telling us
your story
now the last section of our presentation
is focused on the benefits of google
cloud certifications both to individuals
and to companies and the ecosystem
we did a survey in the beginning of 2020
of people who had achieved google cloud
certifications using an independent
third-party organization
of the people that we surveyed 78
said that they had gotten additional
confidence in their professional future
because they got this certification
um 82 percent felt like they now had a
special
way to improve to prove their cloud
skill competency to potential recruiters
83 felt that their resume or cv was now
more attractive to prospective employers
and finally 85 said that they themselves
felt more confident in their cloud
skills
it leaders have also been surveyed about
the impact of certification
out of those who authorized training for
their teams within the last 12 months in
a different survey
two-thirds did so specifically with the
aim of preparing their team members for
certification or recertification
93 of those leaders agreed that
certified employees add value to their
organizations well beyond the sheer cost
of the certification itself
how much was that well 63 of them were
comfortable estimating that the economic
benefit of those certified employees was
more than 10 000 usd a year which is a
significant increment for what is
comparatively a small investment
uh in skills and knowledge
as us as i mentioned there's a wide
variety of uh of benefits for getting
certification and some of them are swag
folks who achieve our professional level
certifications do get excellent
merchandise that allows them to show off
their credentials in public everybody
gets a digital badge that they can put
on their profiles on social media
and display in other ways
uh professional level certified people
also get access to
special events at
google cloud next and other venues they
get access to the google cloud certified
community so that they can exchange
ideas and knowledge with other certified
people and seek out networking
opportunities as well
now
this talk wouldn't be complete if we
didn't have something new to present
in order to help the broad ecosystem get
more cloud and google cloud skills today
we are announcing google cloud skills
boost it's a brand new way to consume
google cloud learning it makes more than
700 labs courses and tools for preparing
for our certifications available
and
for the next month we're making it
available to all of our customers and
partners at no cost
the url is g dot co slash cloud slash
free training and we hope that everybody
listening will take advantage of this
offer and see what we are making
available to help people take their
careers to the next level at this point
i want to thank osaze for joining us
today and telling us his story
and i'd like to thank everyone in the
audience for uh joining us and we wish
you all the best with your cloud careers